Hundreds if not thousands of people
agreed to create a pentagram and summon
the devil. Not just a little picture of
the devil, but there's a Latin phrase
underneath there that says, "Hear us,
Lucifer, and rise from the abyss. Take
our soul." This is not just family fun,
guys. This is a satanic ritual on a mass
scale. Did you know the origins of
spectator sports is literally a pagan
ritual? The ancient Olympics, a
prominent example of spectator sports,
were deeply rooted in religious and
ritualistic practices. total pagan
entertainment package with religious
processions, animal sacrifices, and a
focus on the sacred sanctuary of Zeus.
You can look this up on Olympics.com.
The staged games in Olympia in honor of
Zeus. The Olympics literally have
ceremonies. The opening ceremony, the
closing ceremony, the definition of what
a ceremony is is a formal religious
ritual. We are literally clapping and
cheering for a satanic ritual Satan
doesn't even have to hide. If you guys
ever doubted that we're in the last
days, just look